and they'll try and identify good and
bad bacteria and then recommend a diet
based on that but what they'll almost
always say is if i eat less and eat more
prominently
so you could save yourself a few hundred
dollars by just doing that in the first
place
um but i think you know i think it's got
a lot of potential in the future so
hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video i had the great
pleasure of chatting with professor
david julian mclemontz a distinguished
professor at the department of food
science at the university of
massachusetts
his research uses the basic principles
of physics chemistry and biology to
improve the quality
healthiness safety and sustainability of
the modern food supply he is also the
author of the book future foods how
modern science is transforming the way
we eat so i hope you enjoy the following
discussion
say hi julian thank you very much for
joining me today and welcome to the
cheeky science show
yeah thanks very much for inviting me
it's really exciting to be here
thank you so um last year i read your
book future foods um how modern science
is transforming the way we eat and i
learned so much about
food itself and how it's affecting and
how we can understand it to alter the
modern food supply and beyond that you
you yourself are a researcher and have
been in this field for a long time and i
believe you're the most cited researcher
in food sciences which is just really
impressive so you also have a wealth of
knowledge which hopefully we'll try and
unpack a bit of it um today in this
discussion and so i guess before we jump
into looking at how we can understand
the nutritional value of foods and how
we can
improve
the quality of foods and also the
sustainability an important question to
address first is well what actually is a
food scientist
yeah so food scientist is somebody who
applies you know basic sciences to try
and um make food make the food supply
soft safer
more affordable um more delicious
uh more abundant you know and to address
all the issues around food so we use
things like physics and chemistry and
biology and psychology and you know any
kind of science that is related to food
so for me it's a really exciting area to
be in as a scientist because it's so
relevant to your life and there's so
many different aspects to it you know
ranging from understanding the
interactions between individual
molecules to understanding you know how
it breaks down in your body
uh you know and how we how it feels in
your mouth and then how that affects you
your brain and your physiology
and ultimately your health yeah yeah
exactly and so also there's a lot of
different attributes to a feed and as
opposed to what actually makes up a feed
to the texture of our foods how it what
happens to when it gets digested as you
just mentioned and i think one kind of
key concept we should try and
distinguish at the moment before we talk
about other concepts later on is what is
the difference between nutrients
vitamins and nutraceuticals
yeah so uh so i think a nutrient is i
think
could ever be like macronutrients so
that would be like proteins
carbohydrates and fats so they're the
you know they're present in quite large
quantities in your food and they really
provide mainly provide energy but
there's also some like essential amino
acids and essential fatty acids that you
need for your body to function properly
because they can't make them
uh and then micronutrients will be
vitamins and minerals so these are
typically present in very small
quantities in foods but they're actually
absolutely critical
for ensuring human health
and again your body can't synthesize
them enough concentration so you have to
get them from your diet
and then nutraceuticals are molecules
that you find in sort of plants and
animals so things like curcumin or
carotenoids or polyphenols
that claim to have certain health
benefits so they may help you prevent
heart disease or cancer or diabetes or
something like that but they're not
absolutely critical to your health if
you didn't eat them you wouldn't die
good about that see i think that's
helped to
resolve some confusion over those terms
because i guess often you see people i
guess use the word nutrients when they
mean vitamins and yeah they get mixed up
quite common and so obviously um one of
the reasons that i tried to meet your
book in the first phase is kind of the
fact that i love i love food basically
and i love cooking and i think also
being a scientist myself i often find
that the process of cooking is also very
similar to being a scientist you you
know you alter what it is you add into
the recipe and then
you kind of look at the results and then
you can adjust different things and it's
similar to in a lab you might you know
mutate a gene and see what happens i
mean it's not quite the same but i feel
like that's definitely something overlap
and so obviously your area of work is
looking at something called foods
nanotechnology and how we can actually
manipulate food beyond what is normally
found and actually trying to improve
um some of the nutrients or vitamin
availability in foods so i guess the
question is what actually is
foods nanotechnology and could you
elaborate a bit on what it is that you
you research
yeah so so food nanotechnology is really
studying um
sort of foods and other materials that
are very very small scales on the
nanometer scale so typically it's
between like one nanometer and 100
nanometers and that's a really really
tiny tiny size you know like trillions
of size smaller than us you know like
we're used to
and by making things very very small
they behave in very different ways than
they would normally so for example
you know if you if you think of
something like ant-man you know if you
shrink ant-man to a chinese size he can
do things that he could never do
normally he can get into places he
couldn't get there before and he could
do things he couldn't do before
and it's the same with food ingredients
like by making say a vitamin loaded fat
droplet and we if we nano size it we can
make it much more bioavailable because
when we make it look smaller it gets
digested much more quickly in our
gastrointestinal tract and that releases
more of the vitamins
and they can get absorbed more rapidly
and more extensively into your body so
we do a lot of work in trying to
increase by availability by making
things very very small
so if i understand yeah so you're trying
to use the technology to improve to make
like kind of nano-boosted foods is that
right
yeah so we're trying to sort of boost
the bioavailability of the um beneficial
compounds in foods use nanotechnology so
for example if you eat we did some
experiments recently with dietary
supplements so if you buy like
carotenoids or um from the from
a chemist or something and you eat them
maybe only like five percent of what you
actually eat goes into your body and the
rest of it just goes straight through
your body but we've shown that when we
put them into our sort of nanoparticles
like food grade nanoparticles that you
can boost that up to like 50 or 70 so
you get almost like a tenfold increase
in the amount of the
these beneficial molecules that get into
your body and we've also shown that we
can do it with natural fruits and
vegetables so if you take like a um a
salad for example
and you eat a salad it's got lots of
healthy molecules in called carotenoids
but if you just ate the salad on its own
hardly any of the molecules get into
your body
but if you eat it with one of our
nano-enabled salad dressings you get a
huge increase in the amount of these so
carotenoids get into your bloodstream
and then can have the beneficial health
effects
so i think i recently came across your
ted talk where you use the example of
carrots to explain this kind of concept
and so
like
including carrots like how exactly is
the technology employed to actually be
able to improve the bio availability
yes i mean what we would do is like you
would look at like um common food
products so you might say put a cream on
an ice cream or some fruits and
vegetables or you might put a salad
dressing on a salad or you may have a
cooking sauce like a curry sauce like
you're cooking vegetables in so what we
would do is we would make the nano drop
the droplets in these sauces and creams
and dressings very very small and we
would control their composition so that
they get broken down quickly in your
gastrointestinal tract and form these
tiny little nanoparticles inside your
body that can transport them in into
your gut where they can be absorbed
and so i'm in terms of like seeing
somebody's products on my car shelves um
as we get to our weekly shopping like
why do you foresee um there's technology
being used first or like what kind of
stage of commercialization are you at
yeah there's a
number of companies that we're working
with now so some companies are looking
at um
like the ted talk is like eye health
it's like trying to encapsulate
um
things like lutein and zeaxanthin which
is these carotenoids which are known to
be beneficial to eye health so people
are using the technology to make sure
that they're in the bioavailable form
and the other
where area we're doing a lot of work
with is cannabis companies so like in
the uh in the united states you know
cannabis is legal in a lot of different
states and you can buy it as edibles but
one of the problem with edibles like
chocolate is you get a very low
increase in the cannabinoids in your
bloodstream and that can make you
overeat the cannabinoids because you
think oh i'm not getting effect i'll eat
more and more
yeah and then you can get too high and
you can feel really bad
so what we're trying to do is like put
them into nanoparticles so they get
absorbed very quickly into your
bloodstream so you get the effects
straight away so then you can have it
like um an alcoholic drink you know and
you're going to get the the same kind of
response from it and it's not like
smoking where you're going to get
problems with lung cancer
so it's a you know it's a better way to
get them so it could be for things like
you know if you're trying to use thc to
get a high but also for you know um cbd
if you're trying to do pain management
we can sort of structure these foods so
you get a rapid hit or you can get
sustained release so that you get
different effects depending on what
you're trying to use them for
that's really interesting and so you
kind of somewhat leaded to it but how do
you in terms of trying to understand how
it gets digested in the body how do you
actually mimic that process um in the
allowable do you go directly into muscle
organisms and to patients
yeah so we start off with a like in
vitro digestion model so we simulate the
mouth and the stomach and the small
intestine using basically some test
tubes and we control the temperature and
the enzymes and the saliva you know so
we simulate the saliva and the gas
reduces and the small intestinal juices
and then we see how the food behaves
along there and we can measure what's
called a bioaccessibility so that's the
amount that's uniform that can be
absorbed and then we might do things
like cell cultures so we would incubate
the
digester in in on a cell culture and see
how much of it got absorbed
and how it might get metabolized by the
enzymes in the cells
and then you know once we've i you know
identified a good formulation then we
might test it using animal studies or
human studies
uh so some of we did some studies
recently with you know students where we
fed them salads with these um
nano enabled salad dressings and this is
where we saw these big increases in
carotenoids in the bloodstream
cool um and so also yeah one of the
reasons why you do testing is to also
check for safety and so are there any
potential concerns we should be worried
about in terms of this nano technology
yeah i think with any new technology you
have to be really careful to test it
properly and i think especially with the
food industry because
um you know people you know millions and
millions of people are eating foods
every day so if you do make a mistake it
has really profound implications so you
know we do do toxicology studies as well
using cell cultures and animal studies
to make sure that you know that the
technology you develop are you know are
going to be healthy and not cause any
adverse effects
so i mean some of the effects that you
could have for example with um
carotenoids there was some studies
showing that if you
give people high doses of carotenoids
if they're smokers it can actually
promote cancer you know because um you
know you get it somehow enhances the
free radicals that are generated in your
body uh because there's so there's so
many free radicals at the beginning so
for that population you wouldn't want to
give these kind of systems because if
you're really boosting the
bioavailability and then if you're using
like solid nanoparticles so things like
titanium dioxide
they can they could get into your cells
and maybe accumulate in your cells and
have some adverse effects so it's really
important to study this stuff
and so i guess you kind of raised an
interesting question that was coming out
later on but it makes sense to ask now
which is um personalized nutrition and
how actually it's fully important to
consider differences
in terms of our genetics and i guess our
environmental setting as to what foods
might be best to eat
and the quantities and so i mean what
what do you think we'll see in terms of
personalized nutrition in the future
yeah it's a really rapidly growing area
and i think the science is still really
at the beginning because it's such a
complicated area
um you know so i think traditionally
foods are just designed for a general
population but i think you know now
there's increasing evidence that all
we've all got you know our own genetic
sequences we've all got the
genes are expressed differently
depending on your lifestyle we have
different microbiomes we have different
bacteria that are living in in our um
you know goods and they metabolize foods
differently which is different types of
products
and then you know some people might be
active and some non-active some people
may have diabetes some have heart
disease some of uh hypertension so we
really if we can design specific diets
for specific people then we may be able
to you know emiliate some of the adverse
effects
you know uh health effects that might
happen throughout your life and that
could you know could improve people's
quality of life and reduce health care
costs in the long run
so you mentioned one of my favorite
words now which is microbiome and so how
do you take that into account in terms
of doing these studies or is that
something that
um like it's i guess yeah how do you use
that understanding to design foods and
understand the digestion
yeah i mean the microbiome is incredibly
complicated again you know it's
you know it's like a jungle where you've
got all these different animals you know
you've got like lions and tigers and
birds and insects and stuff and they're
all interacting with each other in this
ecosystem and that's the same inside
your microbiome you've got this really
sort of complicated ecosystem and we
don't really understand what all of
these different components are doing and
like if you take one or two of them out
it's not going to have a big effect on
the overall environment and i mean
sometimes it does you know if it's
imagining like a jungle if it's like
that predator at the top if you take
them out i can have a really big effect
but if it's just
some little mouse something that might
have much less effect
so i think at the moment we're just
trying to understand on the microbial
level you know which are the really
important um microorganisms and how do
they interact with each other you know
and what's the dependence on them so i
think there's a lot of research going on
in this area we have some professors in
our department who are doing this where
you see different foods and you can you
get some really interesting effects for
example with things like curcumin which
you know it's got all these health
effects but as soon as it gets into
microbiome it gets metabolized by the
bacteria there and it changes to all
sorts of different forms and they'll be
more maybe more or less bioavailable or
bioactive than the original form so you
really need to understand that if you
need to understand how these
nutraceuticals are the molecules behave
in your body
yeah exactly and so i mean from that
i've seen a lot of
like companies say that they can i guess
measure your microbiome and so
um i think i maybe read it in your book
or maybe from elsewhere but i believe
that
the way that they do that is somebody
from like a stool sample and like
obviously i've got microbiomes and i've
got so
is that really giving us a
representation of like our own
microbiome
yeah and i think it's it's very hard to
make what you should really do with
zybar do biopsies because i think you
know the things that come out and you're
still
you know probably not the ones that are
residing you know remaining in there so
it gives you some idea of what's going
on in in your
colon but it doesn't give you the
complete picture so again i think it's a
really emerging science um and i think
that there's a lot of companies
especially in america i don't know if
it's the same in the uk that you know
you can send your students still samples
and they'll do microbiome analysis and
they'll try and identify good and bad
bacteria and then recommend a diet based
on that but what they'll almost always
say is if i eat less and eat more
promising
so you could save yourself a few hundred
dollars by just doing that in the first
place
um but i think you know i think it's got
a lot of potential in the future
yeah definitely i think yeah i mean i
always find myself reading the latest
studies on the microbrain because they
seem to just influence even like the
brain due to all the different like uh
metabolites they produce themselves so
yeah i think that's you're right it's
definitely gonna be something that i
think would also influence the area of
food design
so
one thing i thought was really
interesting about that was like you know
it was once to be said you know it's
like the microbiomes are really like
doing brain control on you because you
know depending on what bacteria they
actually want certain like more fat or
something so they'll produce hormones
that will make you um get a lot of
pleasure when you eat fat so you'll eat
more fat and then you'll get that
population will grow so i think that's
interesting this idea that your colon's
controlling your mind that is
interesting yeah because i've had it be
referred to as like your second brain so
it's almost like it takes over
yeah that's what it wants
um so besides um in terms of improving
foods nutritional quality by using nano
technology another area maybe perhaps
with a bit more controversy over it is
the use of um biotechnology to like
genetically modify uh different crops
and so i suppose like when i first was
introduced to term back in like high
school of like gm crops i was also
sharing like newspaper articles saying
like you know franken tomatoes and stuff
but more recently i've seen a company
that's developed um genetically modified
salmon and i believe these salmon have
like an additional copy of a growth
hormone that basically means that they
can grow all year round and so
by doing this they have a better
consistent abundance of salmon and they
also don't have to give them antibiotics
and things like that and so obviously as
well
as um there's evidence that it seems to
be potentially safe there's also
improvements in the technology
themselves in terms of like crispr and
being able to sequence it check there's
no like off target editing
and so i guess yeah my general question
is what are your thoughts around
biotechnology and how do you foresee it
being incorporated into our modern food
supply
yeah and i think that's one of the
things i really learned from doing this
book is you know i think i was quite
skeptical about
genetic engineering and stuff like that
i think oh it's bad for you and stuff
like you know i live in a very liberal
area in america and
in england people are always going
against genetic engineering but like
when you actually read about it you know
there's very little evidence that it has
any adverse effects and there's a lot of
evidence that has very beneficial
effects and i think you know as a
scientist you want to you know you want
to ask questions and you know test
things rigorously and if the evidence
suggests that you know there isn't
adverse effects then we should use any
means we can to try and improve uh the
food supply
and you know i think you mentioned the
salmon but there's lots of other
examples you know where it can be can be
used you know it can improve the
resilience of crops it can so they can
withstand you know high salt levels or
higher temperatures or more dry climates
which is really important if you're
trying to deal with you know the effects
of climate change
um it can be used to like improve the
health profile of things like um like
soybeans you get more omega-3 fatty
acids in the soybeans so they've
genetically engineered those crops but i
think in america we've been eating you
know genetically engineered foods for
decades you know and you know i think
most of the soybeans and corn and stuff
like that is genetically engineered and
there's no evidence there's been any you
know adverse health effects from it
so i think we know for we should use any
science that we can to solve the
problems and the problems are so big you
know with global warming
um
you know and
the devastation of the the bias
biodiversity and stuff like that we just
need to use every tool we can as long as
it's safe
yeah i think that's a really good a good
point to raise like is about just
understanding
what we can get from the literature and
see the current data if it's safe or not
and i guess yeah just have conversations
about it um
i think that's yeah it's
just good to just track and monitor the
process
um
and so now that we've got tools such as
um
nanotechnology and biotechnology i guess
you can kind of we've got kind of a tool
kit to try and boost the quality of
foods and so um
it was a couple of years ago i actually
wrote an essay that i entered for a
prize it didn't win um i wrote it
nonetheless and it was about um
designing potential superfoods and so i
guess um
do you think that there's a way that we
could literally
even like kind of invent or design
so called superfoods or foods that like
if you like what i mean by that is kind
of like foods where
um
when you used to get asked like if you
could eat one food for the rest of your
life of your life what would it be kind
of thing could we actually design a food
that could actually do that
yeah
i don't think we'd want to do that
because i think i mean i was um on a
committee with um
this uh astronaut who used to be like
the commander of the international space
station and he was saying that you know
one of the
worst things about being an astronaut is
that you you know the food is so bad and
i think you don't realize when you're on
earth and you've got all the different
food available you know like how
how one important role that plays in
your life you know that sensory
experience of having all these different
flavors and tastes and fresh food and
stuff like that so they tell you you
know when you're astronaut using this
stars on mush all the time you get
really depressed and you really miss
that so i think we will always want
different foods
but i think we can make sort of soup you
know superfoods in the sense that we can
make them much more healthier and
sustainable if we can really understand
the science behind you know what you
know how to get you know so what makes
them look and feel and taste the way
they do and then how they behave in the
gastrointestinal tract and how we can
control that so that we can reduce the
fat and the sugar and the salt
and we can improve we can put all the
good ingredients that um can combat you
know disease you know so the
nutraceuticals and dietary fiber than
that
without adversely affecting their
quality attributes
and then you know and then carry out
experiments to prove that they actually
work
and i think a great example is you know
like the impossible burger and the you
know beyond meat burger you know like
these are you know these plant-based
foods they're not foods in terms of like
health but in terms of sustainability
they are you know they have a huge
potential have a huge impact on the
environment if we can switch meat in
these animal-based foods to plant-based
ones
so i now that you brought it up um how
exactly are these different foods made
like how how do they make them look so
much like meats but not meat at the same
time
yeah i mean again it's these materials i
don't think people realize here you know
how complicated foods are you know we
have a really good polymer science
department at umass and they work with
synthetic polymers and they're always
talking about how complicated they are
but they've got like one or two polymers
in there you know when we've got food
we've got hundreds of different
molecules in all sorts of different
forms that are interacting with each
other so we've got some you know small
molecules large molecules colloidal
particles and there's all sorts of
different forces holding them together
so i think that's where you know
companies like impossible food and
beyond meat have really
sort of focused on understanding the
fundamental science and then you know
how can i understand what ingredients
are there and what the interactions are
between them and then how that interacts
with
the feel and taste the look and the and
the mouth feel of the product so some of
the things they've done is like simulate
the color so you can go from like a raw
meat to a cooked meat and in terms of
impossible foods what they did is they
said like in real meat you have to have
things like uh hemoglobin which you know
will change color when you eat it from
like a red color to like a brownie color
and then they've identified a molecule
in plants that does the same thing so
soybeans but the problem inside in the
roots of soybeans there's not enough of
that to make the millions of
burgers that you need you know to feed
the uh
the country so what they've done is use
genetic engineering
of yeast cells so that they can produce
this what's called like hemoglobin and
then isolate purify and put it into
these plant-based burgers so you get the
same flavor and
color characteristics so that's one
trick but there's a lot of other tricks
you have to do as well
that's really interesting um and so
obviously and there's been actually
quite like at least to me it feels like
in the last few years we've seen more
and more of these uh plant-based
products not only in like uh like you've
mentioned impossible foods and
i fully mixed the two together that
bottom
um there's also like just in the normal
supermarkets there's all these
alternative plant-based food products
and so i from the sustainability aspect
which we'll talk a bit more about later
i can i understand how great it is that
we see these products now and that
people are um eating them and obviously
i've also read that having a mainly
plant-based diet is also good for your
health and trying to reduce meat intake
but are there actually any concerns to
eating these
like designed plant-based foods in terms
of maybe more salt or anything like that
yeah i think that you know there
definitely is some concerns about me and
i think um you know a lot of people
criticize the the current generation of
plant-based foods because this seems
like highly processed foods so they do
contain you know i mean some of them i
was looking at one recently you have
some like 30 or 40 ingredients in like
one of them and a lot of them were not
natural ingredients so i think just
because it's plant-based doesn't mean
it's healthy for you you know you could
go and eat loads of cakes and they're
all plant-based but they're not going to
you know improve your health
um so i think that's i think the first
generation of plant-based foods is
really designed to improve
sustainability so they're designed to
like start look feel and taste like real
products and people buy them especially
meat eaters will buy them
and incorporate them into the diet and
have these sustainability benefits i
think the next generation we really need
to think more about health as well so we
need to redesign them to make sure that
there's not too much fat sugar and salt
in them and that they do have these
beneficial components like some of the
nutrients that you might be missing from
a plant-based diet so things like
vitamin b12 or vitamin d
so if you eat these products you're
going to get that full you you
nutritional profile that's going to keep
you healthy
so when you mention this kind of like
second wave or second generation of
products like are these currently
already being researched like how long
do you think it'd be until we actually
see some of them
uh i think a number of companies are
starting to do that i know a lot more
academics are doing it now so we just
did some work with um some of my
students are doing some work on some
plant-based seafood and they just made
these fantastic uh scallops i mean i
don't like seafood but they made it and
look and
they look exactly like skeletons exactly
the same texture as skeleton they did a
beautiful photograph on like where they
played and salons around them and you
couldn't tell the difference wow
and they're only made from like um
basically they're made from peas and
orange
they're made from p protein and pectin
which comes from citrus fruit so you
know it's from like these two like i
think there's we had an enzyme to
crosslink them as well translucement but
from these three ingredients you can
make something that looks almost exactly
like a scallop so then you can address
issues like sustainability
you know from the seafood like over over
fishing seafoods and things like that
and pollution associated with that but
again i think the next step is to try
and make them you know make sure they
taste the same and they behave the same
way in your mouth which is probably the
more complicated
um step
yeah made for saturn um i mean it's
already i already think it's crazy that
what they produced is so similar so yeah
it's a thing that it could even get
closer it's just incredible to think
about
but so i suppose in terms of
sustainability
besides making plant-based alternatives
the alternative to that is to still have
meat but instead of getting it from
actual livestock is to
have say called cultured meat or lab
grain meat and you use
the example in your book i believe the
company's
called eat just and um there's something
about they they've created
um cultured um meat which initially came
from a chicken and say there was this
chicken they had called ian and they
took
they took uh some cells from in and then
they created these chicken nuggets and
they were eating the chicken nuggets
whilst ian was like walking about them
so i was just wondering like um how does
this process work what are the steps
involved in cultured meats
yeah so typically you have to isolate
some cells usually from a living animal
and then you culture them in usually and
you can do it in a laboratory in a petri
dish but usually we're doing a big
fermentation tank industrially
and then so you would put it in a broth
that had the nutrients that the cells
require the growth you have to do a lot
of research to find out what those
nutrients are and then you need to add
growth factors
uh which are going to make the cell sort
of grow like divide and grow and
multiply and then typically you have to
have some kind of external force
which stimulates them to sort of link
together and form these like fibrous
kind of structures that you would get in
in real meat so i think one of the big
challenges in that area has been to find
suitable growth factors so i think they
use like some called bovine fetal serum
which you actually have to get from like
you know
a fetus that's come out of a cow you
have to put it open and get the blood
from it and that's you know obviously
that's not suitable for vegetarians yeah
vegans
and it's um
yeah yeah it's just not a desirable way
to get it so i think what they're trying
to do now is to find like plant-based
alternatives
uh to to obtain those kind of things
obviously one of the the things that
kind of attracted me to this that of um
of science is the fact that i'll say i
grow cells in the lab like that's what i
do all the time and so obviously i know
that actually doing this is quite
expensive like the having the incubators
using all the sterile equipment like how
actually feasible is this approach going
to be in the future are we going to be
able to reduce the cost of this
procedure
yeah i think that's always been a big
question i think they're getting closer
and closer to doing it i mean sometimes
i just food from san francisco claim
that you know in the next couple of
years or something they're going to have
you know commercial products that are
economically viable i think what they'll
tend to do with the first is that
they'll take like really high-end
expensive products
um because the costs are going to be a
lot so i think in singapore the the
government has just um allowed um
cultured meat to be consumed i think
there's a restaurant that actually sells
it in singapore now so people are
queuing up to buy this really expensive
i think it's a chicken kind of product
that's been grown you know basically in
a test tube
um so i think it will in the in the
future
it probably will become economically
viable
but i imagine maybe on a small scale to
start with but if you look at how big
the meat industry is i think that's the
challenge is like how do you like
replace all this meat because that's the
only way you're gonna have a really big
impact on the environment
yeah that's true um and yeah i guess if
we want to have mainstream adoption to
more sustainable options
it has to we have to find some kind of
way of reducing the cost such that as a
consumer you would choose a product that
is more affordable than
um the actual meat option so yeah i
think it's really important but i
suppose one of the interesting outcomes
of this kind of cultured meat technique
is like
the kind of creepy idea that we could
take our own cells
and start growing them and create my own
meats and i don't want to elaborate a
bit on that yeah i think i wrote about
that in the book but i think it was just
like it's a bit of a weird idea i think
you know principally could do that like
would there be some anything wrong with
that like eating yourself
you know especially if you're a
vegetarian you know like you're not
harming anybody but yourself and you're
not even harming yourself but i wouldn't
do it i mean i think i at the moment i
don't even know if i would eat lab grown
meat even though that you know i'm a
vegetarian and i know it'd be much more
sustainable i think i'm just so used to
not eating meat
yeah again i would eat a plant-based
meat even if it tastes exactly like real
meat so it's strange you know like what
makes you have those decisions
we're actually talking about kind of
like food perception um and like how
actually some of these changes
will require us to like i guess surpass
like previous conceptions about foods
and that brings on to the whole
huge field of like gastrophysics and how
there's
more to feed than just the three
components and how it's digested it's
about how we smell foods and how we are
like if we mentioned the microbiome
might be influencing what kind of foods
we're we're desiring and so i believe um
i learned from your book that around
85
of the flavor of a food actually doesn't
come from like the taste it comes from
like just the aroma the smell of it and
so it has the interesting implications
that
if we want to like alter our perception
to eat foods that maybe are healthier
for us but we don't really want to eat
it we could just maybe alter the smell
of it such that we're like oh i really
want to eat this
healthy plate of foods because it smells
amazing like you can make it smell
something that like a burger or
something but you'd be really wanting to
eat it like is that something that's
potentially possible in the future
yeah i mean definitely people are
looking into that so i think i mean the
important things are like you're looking
at the type of molecules that provide a
particular smell you know it's it's very
complicated you know like it's you know
if you have like a strawberry smell it's
not one compound that makes it
strawberry i think it's like
30 or 40 or more compounds that really
contribute to that strawberry smell so i
think you have to like look into nature
and do like analysis using things like
gas chromatography or mass spectrometry
to find out what all the different
molecules are and what the balance of
those molecules are and then you have to
have people sniffing at the spectrometer
to find out you know which of these
flavors are important and which ones are
not and then you have to you know be
able to put those back into the into the
food system and then it's also important
it's like how quickly they get released
do they get released very fast or very
slowly so i think in the book i use the
example of like an orchestra you know
you've got all these different
um instruments that are playing to
create the overall sound and it depends
the time in it when they're when each
one of them plays so you have to make
sure that they all get to your nose at
the right time to get that you know like
a meat flavor if you're doing a plunger
or fish flavor or something like that so
again like all of this is incredibly
complicated and it involves you know
fundamental chemistry and physics but
also sort of biology and you know um
psychology so i think that's what makes
it such an interesting area to work and
i think
yeah unless you think it must like you
must cover pretty much every discipline
of science right it always seems that
way
yeah there isn't you're doing something
that we're all familiar with you know
like something you you might cook and
eat every day so that's what i love
about it
exactly and um i guess to continue in
this um area of like gathering physics
i've seen some interesting research
where they combine food consumption with
use of either augmented reality or like
virtual reality whereby
i guess a similar way to manipulating
like the aroma for foods you can alter
what you see so like you see
um
i think the example they have is just
like a cup of coffee and or maybe it's
tea and the idea is it has
the actual physical tea has no milk in
it but what they see is milky and so
they drink it thinking and it you know
altered their perception such that they
assume that they're having just a normal
cup of tea but actually it's very
different and so i mean again do you
have any insights into this area of
research
yeah only where i learned from writing
that book and i think it was like
professor charles spence who does a lot
of work things at university of oxford
in england so yeah he does like a lot of
fantastic work in that area
um but i think again you know that could
be important for things like you know
people may be suffering from obesity you
know maybe if you had something like
that when you were eating um it looks
like you're eating a lot but you eat
much less than you are or the calorie
density is much lower
um on the plate than it looks like it
looks really fatty or creamy in your eye
so you know like they could be really
useful to certain things
i guess maybe another area um where it
could be useful is
if we ever come to eating insects i know
you discuss baths in your book as well
um like for me i mean i think of insects
might kind of shiver a little bit but
you also mentioned in your book that
actually we're probably already eating
insects so could you explain what you
mean by that
yeah and i think like if you go to the
usda united states department of
agriculture website and you look at
different kind of food products you can
go through a whole list of food products
and it'll tell you like what's the
maximum amount of say insect eggs or you
know fly larvae or body parts that you
can have in each one you know something
like tomorrow's might have been like
might be 50 legs or something like that
so i think we know we just you just
don't want to look basically so i think
like one of the professional departments
said she taught the class where she
needed to open the kind of tomatoes and
she put it under the microscope and you
could just see lots and lots of insect
parts in there
lovely
so i guess in terms of um
like why why would insects be a
potential more sustainable option as
opposed to uh meats
yeah so i think you can um they first of
all a really good nutritional profile
not all of them but you know some of
them have you know the higher omega-3
fatty acids they've got good quality
protein in them they've got lots of
vitamins and minerals in them so you can
get all the nutrients that you need uh
similar to me
then they can just be grown uh in large
numbers at a you know
much
lower environmental impacts you need
less water less land use
there's less greenhouse gas emissions
less energy use overall so there's a lot
of you know advantages from the
sustainability point of view so i think
that's what what the big motivation for
eating these things is and i think as
you said that the most the biggest
hurdle is like this yuck factor
is you know like it's you know
especially in the west a lot of us just
don't want to eat anything that's got
insects in because you think it's you
know it's dirty or inspired or something
but as i think i said in the book it's
like already two billion people around
the world just commonly insects they
don't even think about it you know
they're completely fine with it so i
think we can we can definitely change
so what would be the insects that have
like the high nutritional quality
um
i can't remember off the top of my head
i think it's a
meal worm i think they're typically used
a lot but there's lots of other things
like grasshoppers and other things like
that yeah i mean i used i have a put
some packets in my office i like uh when
i teach my future foods class
i bring some insects in and i you know
i'll say to the students in the class i
love like two snacks behind my back and
you want to make a really unhealthy
snack that potentially could make you
sick or you're gonna make a much more
healthy one they're all let's have a
healthy one so i'll put the
the crisps aside and take out the insect
and some of them are really brave and
they'll eat them
because they've got nice flavors now
they've got like barbecue flavors our
chocolate coated ones and all sorts of
different ones
yeah i think it'll be really interesting
to see um i guess what will happen in
terms of that and how we can maybe alter
our perception and maybe or whether it
is just going to be a kind of more of a
novelty
um factor to eating insects and i guess
i think another way you could do is kind
of like grind them up and have them more
as a flower so you wouldn't have to
really like necessarily look at them if
that was
the main concern
yeah we've done some work on that it's
like taking you know insects and then
you can break them down to different
parts and you can use some of them as
functional ingredients like emulsifiers
or gelling agents so yeah you don't
actually see it in the final product it
just looks like a regular food
that's really interesting yeah because i
i mean yeah i think it
yeah that's i don't know i think insects
affect people differently um
yeah
um
so yeah talking about i guess like
future foods like how are we going to be
able to to feed the growing population
and like
what where do you foresee like what
foods are we going to be eating and
let's say
a shorter time scale and then like maybe
by 2050 what do you think is going to be
the norm for us to be eating
yeah i think that i mean i think the
most important thing i think in the
short term is like switching to a
plant-based diet so if we can get more
and more people switching from eating
you know sort of especially beef like
you know beef lamb pork chicken and eat
in plant-based foods i think that will
be you know that will have a really
major impact
uh and then again i think using a lot of
you know reducing waste i think food
waste is enormous isn't like 30 40 of
the food we produce is waste so like if
we can try and reduce that as much as
possible
then making the agricultural system more
efficient so i think using a lot of
automation so we may have sort of robots
that will
you know like plant the foods and then
monitor them over time and then
instead of just like watering everything
every day or putting pesticides or
fertilizers on every day we we do almost
like personalized nutrition for the
plants so you look at like what each
plant needs and you just give it what it
needs to to grow healthily and get a
high yield so we can reduce a lot of the
waste
and fertilizer using pesticide use that
way and then i think using some of these
biotechnology techniques like um
you know crispr another kind of gene
editing to make plants more resilient
and have better yields and better
nutritional profiles
so um you mentioned an interesting area
which is the kind of monitoring of the
fees with robots and i believe that also
kind of comes back a little bit to the
nano technology
and like how exactly is that
incorporated into the
crops and what exactly is it that
they're monitoring
yeah so i think you can monitor all
sorts of different things i think you
know they use a lot of spectroscopy
methods um and and use
and they can have them in satellites
which are you know like way up in the
sky or you can just have drones that
will fly across across the field or even
little robots that will stop scurry
across the ground and you can you know
like fire like um electromagnetic waves
at these leaves or stems
and you can get information about things
like whether they're contaminated by you
know um toxins or by are they being
infested by insects or you know what
their nutritional profile is at
particular time and you know maybe like
if we want to get high protein or
omega-3 we should be using this kind of
fertilizer or we can really discriminate
what kind of tests or what kind of
problem they've got so we can use you
know this kind of pesticide
so you can be much more like precise
about how you how you treat the plants
um
yeah and in terms of nanotechnology we
do you know we've done some work on nano
pesticides where you again instead of
having these great big particles with
the either the
uh the antimicrobials and you can shrink
them to tiny sizes and that means that
they can get into like insects bodies
more easily and kill them more quickly
we're trying to do that using like all
natural
antimicrobials so things like essential
oils so essential oils are produced by
plants naturally secondary metabolites
to protect themselves from insects and
another kind of contamination so we like
isolate them and then create them into
nanoparticles and then we can use them
as natural fertilizers
well that's super interesting like i
yeah i wasn't really aware of that um
that's super cool
um so i guess in terms of talking about
exciting advances what is it that you
would say you're most excited about like
which area of research do you think is
looking really cool you think for me i
think uh i mean i've done a lot of work
with bioavailability and delivery
systems but i think recently our labs
really switched over to the soft
plant-based food area because i think
this is just like the most
important area to have an impact so
we're like we're trying to make you know
practiced egg plant-based cheese campus
seafood plant-based meat plant-based
milks and to try and make them you know
get the quality bedroom better so what
we really want is like we want people
who love meat or love fish or love
cheese
they've got these two products and they
both taste exactly the same you know
they both got the same cost but one of
them has been produced by animals one
hasn't and if we can get to that stage
and we can make people switch
then you know we can have a really big
impact
but the science is incredibly
complicated yeah which isn't interesting
yeah because you mentioned eggs right
and like i mean
how how to go about trying to make a
plant-based alternative for an egg
because just like the whole process of
the different ways you can cook them
like that's just how how do you get
about trying to solve that problem yeah
like like again that couldn't be just so
this is it we just had this this morning
for breakfast this is like a plant
um but they've done a really good job of
doing it but what you can do is um you
have to identify what the key proteins
in some egg white and egg yolk so things
like albumin and then when you heat them
those proteins unfold and they become
more hydrophobic and they all stick
together and that's what makes it like
form a gel so what you're trying to do
is you're trying to identify proteins in
plants which will behave in a similar
similar fashion
um so
what you really want is one fold at the
same temperature because each protein it
unfolds at different temperatures so
we've made some like reasonably good
plant-based eggs that can mimic the
properties of you know relax
so you're speaking about the challenges
of trying to create these um plant-based
food products what are the other major
challenges that you think is facing the
the more mainstream adoption of
plant-based alternatives
i think part of it's cultural especially
in america i mean i think you know we
can't get people to take vaccines even
if it's going to save the life i think
some people think you know if you're
eating plant-based foods there's
something wrong with you
you know it's like it's something like
maybe hippies do or liberals do
so i think it's trying to you know get
over that sort of cultural barrier it's
going to be really important thing
but i think you know if we can make
really really high quality products you
know and make make them cheaper you know
and healthier then i think you know
you'll get more and more consumers doing
that and i think that it'll grow faster
and faster i mean it's already really
fast growing area
yeah
yeah i think the other really important
areas just
you know there is a lot of problems with
the food in you know the food supply in
terms of you know that it's causing lots
of health problems especially you know
obesity and diabetes
but other diseases as well so i think we
really need to carefully think about
what people actually eat and you know
what are those foods that are causing
those problems and how can we redesign
them so people can still enjoy them and
incorporate them in the diet but they're
not going to have the adverse health
effects that they do
exactly
um so
i'm kind of we'll wrap up i suppose what
kind of advice would you give um i guess
from two perspectives one is
like um someone listening wanting to try
and eat more hopefully and then secondly
someone who's interested in you know
becoming a food scientist themselves
like what kind of advice would you give
yeah because i think you know trying to
eat healthily i think you know i think
the most important thing is to eat
plant-based foods and trying to you know
whole foods if you can so it's like
fruits vegetables you know nuts legumes
and things like that if you can you know
if you use processed
protein foods that's fine but you'll
look at the label you know and just make
sure there's not too much you know
saturated fat and sugar and salt in
there
and i think become a food scientist um
you know i just sort of fell into it
because i think my influence improved
science when i was
doing my a levels and i had no clue what
i wanted to do and i thought that sounds
interesting
um but i think yeah i think we'd we'd
love to have you it's just such an
interesting area to work in so if you're
passionate about science and you're
passionate about foods i think food
science is that just the whole area is
taking off incredibly at the moment and
i think you would have a really exciting
career working in this area
and i think you'd really enjoy you know
enjoy learning about it and you know i'm
continually learning all the time i've
done this for over 30 years and i'm
still really excited about food science
and the changes that are going on in
this area
thank you that's really good advice um
as if anyone wants to find out more
information about your work or i'm just
the field in general like um where can i
like help to direct them
yeah i think you know that future books
is i think there's a good place to start
just to see what's going on in general
in the food area um
you can look on our website i mean if
you're interested in plant-based foods a
good food institute in america has a
fantastic website where they have loads
of information about um cellular
agriculture and
lab grill meat and plant-based foods
and all the different companies that are
doing that and all the science behind it
so i think there's there's a lot of
places you can look now
i think the bbc has some fantastic um
documentaries as well recently
um follow the food or something is it a
really nice series that they had on
recently
oh cool i actually pointed that out i
don't actually watch so much tv but yeah
thank you and yeah just thank you for
coming on today it's been great to pick
your brain i mean your knowledge is
incredible and i think what you're doing
is so important in terms of trying to
promote not just the nutritional value
of foods but also making it more
sustainable which i think we can all
agree is a very important problem to try
and solve for our futures so yeah just
thank you very much
yeah well thank you very much for having
me on it's been a real pleasure doing
here so i hope you've learned something
in this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening